à la veille de noël les rues
commerçantes de lima la capitale sont
bondés une période de fêtes crainte par
les autorités sanitaires alors que le
pérou enregistre après les états unis le
taux de décès par habitant le plus élevé
au monde
lié aux coronavirus
non à la mosquée la seule qui ne faisons
pas de sa nouvelle le dernier pour nos
parents pour nos grands parents alors
s'il vous plaît nous demandons à la
population de nous aider si la
population fait sa part nous aurons à
nos morts dans les hôpitaux
plus tôt dans la semaine le président
par intérim francisco agassi avait
appelé les péruviens à ne pas baisser la
garde et à éviter les grands
rassemblements de personnes
[Musique]
oui j'ai peur j'ai déjà eu le kobe deux
mois d'avril je serais tombé malade à
miami et j'étais très mal pendant
presque un mois
mais j'ai pris soin de moins grâce à
dieu ce serait mieux si le gouvernement
mettait en place des mesures de
quarantaine pour que nous ne soyons pas
infecté car ce sera pire avec les fêtes
des mesures de quarantaine difficilement
applicable alors que 70% de la
population active travaille dans
l'économie informelle
autre facteur aggravant selon une
récente enquête gouvernementale
seulement 22% des familles des quartiers
populaires du pérou possède un
réfrigérateur obligeant celles qui n'en
possèdent pas se rendre régulièrement
dans les marchés de rue lieu où le virus
se propage facilement une crise
sanitaire
mais les crises politiques aboutissant
en novembre dernier à la décision du
président marc vizcarra accusé de
corruption
le nouveau président péruvien francisco
à gatineau mais par le congrès s'est
quant à lui engagé à organiser des
élections l'année prochaine un nouveau
gouvernement qui a du mal à acheter des
vaccins contre le coronavirus auprès des
laboratoires internationaux accusant
récemment l'administration de vizcarra
de ne pas avoir conclu auprès de pfizer
bio ntech un achat de près de 9 millions
de doses de vaccins